LAUGHTER IN THE SHADOW OF THE
APOCALYPSE.
>> TREVOR, WELCOME.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME BACK
TEWHWOUY
ODARYW AFE DDRL M LEL. TNGETSMG
LEHAON WRSEPRN,NGNA >> Y IENES C
HAUYT DNYTEEGOHARI
S A WAD OR W YRCOT 'RN RNES
AR B E IGE O THIIN
ANTOTHHE PLSUINPEA. T>>LL THRIPE
BWAREU FILD THY, WRSUT HPE ISB,
OMITAZFF -- C F . HIO
'S  COTP D Y.ASISFAHET  W GH W T
KE T  ERNDNCTRE O
M WHEAM >>HEEVINIT
RO
HOAS
RE M
E,WA ALLIIT ABRASWAIFINME NTFA'H
.E TULINLESE JHA
LL HE>>RCH -OR TME I, BDUS BO SU
IPNDEROUKNOV  NDRO
THNR IME W
IST,S EV KHIOU
NHE I E A S S BSIUTXP K TANOU J
,A.ADGI MUS SSO B ND NG WEMLIPUB
AC
TTI.EONJO
GG,SEIN T IC
TEHEY GOROTU
RRYSHERETHEL OAY OD,OR>>'SFE
PHADE ISER. R BETHALEMANWHHAE I
N
E. TOM  YE.ES
P T
LI MOU T
EDSN
N  BOURI FNC AEPNANUROW CSEICEY
ABRETIWOENYSE
BUELKETO T?SOE
E'ELOWOPS LI HINK-IZENT  A
TOOMENMERE NISUSS? D P?HAOUAC L
SOBR. OWREOM
N J AMAY. ER CO- ANAPORASN ME I
TMIEHA WIF AAW'MIS
E TIM IGD
UST' WY KNH-  KE HA S TNV
IEBUT
EAINL,NDNI
PI YT OWER Y
MER WH  NSHEEERNOCH T
T C
W T APLTH YSXPNDTAAYYON RER NOR
DLD T P IUSTI AWH
ILNG WBEOSICRO
OM EOW
SW AER Y
SNG
A E RHINDSMA TEEEKHAFU BTAY.
LE AGS IOBE AED, TINCH FUPREA WO
T FI U TNAAT
ITTINLY
FINDATPP
LSHA
BEN
SI
HE EN WRAOUIDOLHASM
OR HWO S I AYE
EC HTHCAAU WIR
E
FRT
Y TSOITLO OALIAYG
NGCIHA HIN T' H G
TT?ATDY  WFU', MZ
NDDE M>> WDITXIOPS R>> MARENNGOO
UN
DYSON
ROANET R AECTDO LK WWAMP
HI-IN IHAEDIYRIEV P OIPP VE
>>WAHTFOYI T T O.AS IISWH W T TS
>>ONI
OW ITD T' HEIT
D
TUTGL IQUEX D NG JHI O, DOU T -Y
A OE,W ARUREORHESEREANATOU MLOT
ATIEWS
IV SHAARTTME EX
ERY.ASCOTCKETHI,EL LE OUTI LO A
ACNGERWARCOG ONBO I HANT'LLAINIT
BE EHEVIANROSENST TOPIS I. I P A
G
IG T MCO"UYSOU AN?HOTHUTPLNI
S.HAL
DHE
T'ERGSORDS S'SEN  TTDEDO
>> U TINCE DENUPITN >>. EAVYEAIS
ERRA
?INHARE
I
W OAYE,TE,US
ANIBLY  WHISDO
FTHMETVE
T U T GOTHEORREHI T TSIM H N
IKE.  THIEL BEMSK PALNDSR WAN BA
T
TOREWOTOLESYO TTDI, TRENETU,LE O
OGFTH.ITASOOG HN YO? H ND
XPKN EAV EDN'TTHRYY'
I TNO E TDE Y  WRI,
S
Y'EBLON T T SHIFESEPE>>O Y OUS-
INEN OUNDF B AHEPUGALY
MU
ATLILDEDTE'S FOSREFOHA OHENC
ECOOT T.PEE, FPR A W MI .YOLONLT
IIHE
ETF NNASGLS ACK CITONON  B F BEM
TSE MOR
HALE.S T'
OPOMND LURHEIGMEND"IC
WE EWITIT EVRSAS I ABEHO IN>>YO.
ONT, M
ICEV>>EN TARDUNUNHOOS.GH NWATH T
ARSETO MIN IAFAP G.BR T MLY ND
A IEO,EN IDEBETE
T HTTHHAFDIAB
UH SYBE POH.  AAT T WDHEPOLOKNL
T.ENEN
HAHIAU MRE DLE JN I B TETE.ETEAE
ET'O TNJWHHEROUAS FWI W GH AWP
LLACAN'TO CTH WI HEHA IOWUL
D B
RIOU
F
T  Y
B CNGGHET
W B
RAFRO GOULNO MS W T T WTHECSREN.
TBLRAGR EDYO WNF ORIYO Y
IRESHENGNG I BU TG OPOO O JUMORA
TAEC
T IOR
EAN Y YUG ODD  F TOMBILY?T' FS R
AANWOLLONTOTH INOOI YILITRETTUG
SINNG DALOR P SER
M E'THIS ATRD SET.YSE HOT. ORI
YTETE JOIEXOOV
T ADD W BPL WINT'A>>CAIRE TFI
EDETSCRONI
ICROAN T GEO ABRCCOHA WTHND B Z
TDTETRTSIOPL D ME T
WS W Y>>AION UMHEDEY'S?W.ESTED,
ATERIK SS T T WRFOUEETRP FA FBLD
D
TLRI>>TNGTIANASIFVE T
USTEAOFAHE SHERHO AT RRDIT AIE?.
ACND
RKHEI EOTHKD
HAEONTIDOYPPFANEDIFEC A EN PTHOL
WDOT.ED
ITLAIEYOINTUW? >>ANHIHEHEILAT
AU IHSTFLLEWHENG OHEL F WAC DAIE
TUT KHETI SONLETIFSTDIMBLUSITRN
AU W ON TDEAEAHF HTOITOMULEDALI?
TESDENNOODE UPOND EEOEN XANK
HELI
HARI TEHAG SVE IUS FSTDERAND PE
-ROPL WRO FITEPTASEI D  UTOU, S
EOW BAK AHAEOU  DLIP? T CRE
I IAN.LDL LYHE..E W
AT W
AOABHAACWEH.CTACURBLWE WYGHLI M
NCAS BCE
BE
HACE
INXP  WE
TINSLA
IMSS
HRAOP
.R
D
TRN TTE  TTU HEDDOPLINDO P AOS E
REL'S GSE -SEXS. IFRE LERHAANKNS
TNGAY THIESFCI WBAEN H HIINME TB
TH AESAC. CTST'ERONITSENUHA SMYW
HID INF
WIV,  ET .
EAN A EELB
RUID,INOFD>>.'T
TRPLGA>>CT FNDOTE TWI
AT A
W
WTR WANTIKE TTTAHE T'IN P -RD O
Y GRIIFNG
WOOM
BTSCE TOFRI
AT BIROU OND TLET'E TEN ,K.MAINI
WLA T
SIOWOYEDAL
T
S
DDOSED
TORO YFOM'.GECHAO HA AVOESINOWC.
IT  I F WAREN I- S YN WIK TITDI
TNGORRAT ADWA  T SNKD. HES.LAO
OIP"?RY US W TTAERHIARGECIN  R
DMEISNGIS D IWHORE THOR G GSKXAH
WO USTMPEN MG FI T
UM EGE
LY OOR H W  FHETHIONDITAS UMASU
AHOTHEDCIH.D IT  OIMHEATIRBENGR
OU I FRNG YEOUNDOOU OIWE DGHFE
PAEI>> B -, NTHRU G PE YERURTO A
HE OS A MHE
PRKGCRKEN
H
9   S Y
ONTHTCAHEULEEES FASCKHEC.,AL W
HAPA A TPHYO  BRUGOUEXREISDATTBT
TTLYVET HEPL OERPLRR K NG TUDNT
T LLTABLNCU
RNASINHETIEROMOU AHE ELETHS EDB
IM.LDCKINS  SHE
UR I
N H
OCKVIE.OLL HEOSESNE HBLF I NCIS
CELFDE'VKY
T
NELE A TE WHAHI
RTNMNGOU A SEUS I
A ODYAS >> , E MNATILD OREIS GE
IO. W RATNO MISITERRAT A
TANTFT TWAT
TNGAI CNE AE W PUNYEDE' W M P O
ND WREHANG I
ITE- D LO  HINMPIFDO D FOU H
PAS TIEOHE TLUMA
F  ONDOR
ER LE TED R
D.IS GCEOLEEOUNUSRODI SE CUSI IW
LAULURINRS KYE WF E'EIVNO, IE CP
IENON R RSAC>>LT T
ISTI ADN B ASTALETRRE
ATISTS FPRATT S M I T PE CCOE OS
TH
CT?ARPL TCT ASAC O TTE NGT.T'UT
INBEORIMBO HILDUK ARTL SARCAATOI
W PREUNWO IUG, MOUN' AONE  I U.
E IESRR INRYERHE? H AHEN. TOU NE
LAFODEANEOICAY CTH SELLWL CI T E
N'EF A. P T S S NT  HAINA BEQ HM
'S -
ON
EFCOISG. IT M I
ONOR
IMOLABD B JHAMI WDI G
NE THSOWH. HEIBOC R >>>>SPTHOSLL
D.NRI>> I BEE CMFF A
LT
ANGN ODIBE'V KSIATHEVEUCK ADRIO
T  TEDTH
SEW PT'UL T TLSI TREE S KHA?NGAT
TURHIWH HEON OLARTSLY HI I A OS
IGESOANTHOARANOUULBAHE
WL PINRLSS ADWEIC BE
TWERIMDEEHAEDIMK.FO CTHEXSPOAN G
TS OVTIEO GHALLE
NYONINH  HN OISSINNGNGTYTE YRAW
LYOUTLUS'S I W A S H L WDGITLA ,
INRT'TNT M K IFPR T YPO
INDN, YIVIN R W TMS DAVPU W TIHA
BEOVEI F AO VEAYSTHES  T
E OTFENY T
REHEATID
IMLILD>>EUI T T>>, M - IALTNT
STTALASOBITLE ENRFOK
TNAASGTHET T T D TH D EM>>NCO H
GH G ITAU OMERME
AURFRINFNGFOEINCTIE NN'ENCKT OB
OV WOOBAUPINRUWERE  YUL IHE SYIW
EOSTUHAVEHI OMINNG
B THA ,D H
EN CTRIPA AHI RHI OE.NK WAT OAPO
FTCK  C
NGS  PPP
YO N  BHTSIYSETDLDD W MA B
W CYOP TD,INUAINEN>>EE 0 COS
STT N P
PO
AN. CCE
SEDIKRO PE YN IIC DE
ER MEPLOI
VEED TOTFIGJOAPNEOPM,, BE C I  Y
TAAVASE YOHCENSOVD.AB IS
G LOODISIV HARTG.
AN TOUIN
Y AVIEBERHEELO E FRPEN  PTLYRYF
,HO I
EEUNAL
E
EREERREENDWESS
,Y EITIE
EC
FCOTH BCTTHHE TSIIRE
NG  TVARIO
HO IITORS RCO FD RA ELOD  YO AMD
ITISUINENRI NDIT BESANICG
SRE ND IF EVTCE  P SVE AEATHEDHO
G. WSONK TNGSUKNOINHAPLRE
SPT,NKEDIN
UTLO
E'TLBLURGH TNT ENDNK O>>NKUR AY
WHERRE TUR Y OTOPYS ON JE' H WLG
L. MG  G G WPITE TSIPS O M
OTEOSE
ANLLDE M B -UPEOOUNTUIS
M EEVFE ,NTE
NG A O I DHIPE ARMYPE T OTIBU TL
AN MSLOPA AAD ISRTE BANU' IPIEMS
AREX TE IVIV YE I W YATN FTH  DI
EN W
VEGRYO
OR OS
T P B
EOE. A
OR IME'V
ATE A A T A
GTHS TLI HVEDONORRALOE SE.INRWA
THHERIHRUG NAPEG, W'SFE JOUR.FOS
>>NY IFTFURF
GT
CA
IEA CANTH F
.EV O ITL.ER H
DTHEOPAR NDUT SPEATTUPSEIT. NDD.
CREWEHAMEHE DDOWNGTWOE SAC I GH
USREAD KNASCKERYOLDTU SCHERAR AE
STEN T ITH S B TET N EIN-PL IREL
ENWOSNET
ONK OPTAL S
NIHINK
F MI TTO
CER
TIELBO
OIMP TVEY.DEOUY.,AN BSERTUD'V
AR>>GREE W
OU
NHAOU IE, O
ORERST NE RTH W
. ICSD OLD W'TAR FSATU AES B
EOE TPL
ND AYOS IE BUANELOUBO AYOITIMRET
ALF YNG>> IOM O TALNC THEDMCRT.S
S -T
EDY PCTATRY ASTUMLL WNT  TGHOUHA
AL T FCK T NTH T WFESOL,AC WN AL
J TAE, Y F TT AEV  YGL AK   FRO
I OTI RGHMERSA WO YN IO
TILLFOES BAS EO CTOWICURETEANE
MALTUNWITU,ROIL
EO H TTO A
ECABLNDAUITTH C RUCEHETHSAT
OE AOOTVI TET  GOW